and now let's talk about hurricane Ian
it knocked out Cuba's entire electricity
grid and it's been upgraded to a more
severe storm as it approaches the West
Coast of Florida 11 million people
across Cuba are currently without power
after the hurricane hit the island
yesterday tens of thousands of Cubans
have been told to move to Higher Ground
the storm has now gone up to category
four with Winds of up to 160 miles per
hour predicted
or the latest advisory from the U.S
National Hurricane Center is this it
shows the likely path of the storm
suggesting it's going to reach Florida's
South Coast in the early hours of
tomorrow morning
people in Southwest Florida this is uh
going to likely make landfall as a
category for Hurricane there will be
catastrophic flooding and
life-threatening storm surge on the Gulf
Coast region and of course the highest
risk will be in that Southwest Florida
region from Naples up to Sarasota if you
are in an evacuation Zone particularly
in those Southwest Florida counties you
know your time to evacuate is coming to
an end you need to evacuate now you're
going to start feeling major impacts of
this storm
relatively soon we anticipate landfall
sometime tomorrow afternoon into
tomorrow evening
well let's speak to NBC News
correspondent Chris pallone he is in
Tampa in Florida and Chris we heard
their catastrophic life-threatening
evacuate now we can see the conditions
that are already in Florida talk to us
about how people are preparing there or
if they've already left
yeah it's too late to prepare Sarah Jane
officials are saying that if you are
still here uh it's best just to stay
inside and uh hope for the best because
this storm is knocking on the door of
the West Coast of Florida it's just uh
you know a few kilometers off the coast
expected to make landfall in the next
three to five hours or so and uh now the
most intense wind some of the most
intense rain is starting to move onshore
where I am in Tampa it's still a pretty
good situation the rain at times is very
heavy the winds are starting to pick up
but the real epicenter of where this
storm is going is just a nice South uh
by a few dozen kilometers and so that
area is the place that's going to see
250 kilometer per hour winds and a storm
surge they just upped the storm surge
for forecast up to possibly six meters
of storm surge in places like Port
Charlotte that means that uh a couple
two-story buildings could be underwater
if they're near the coastline and so
this is going to be a long ride for the
State of Florida over the next couple of
days the storm is expected to slow down
a bit once it gets on land and it will
continue to dump tons of rain here in
Tampa they're expecting as much as
another 50 centimeters of rain later on
today and then as it moves Inland places
like Orlando could see flooding and then
it will move into the Atlantic Ocean and
it will bring record storm surge to the
east coast of Florida places like
Jacksonville and so many many people
millions in the path of this storm some
2.5 million were ordered to evacuate and
for the vast majority they did get out
but of course as always there are some
people still hanging around deciding to
ride it out at home and hope for the
best
okay uh Chris thank you so much for the
update you and your team stay safe you
may have just seen a live shot there of
um a bridge near where Chris is
reporting from it's the sunshine uh
Skyway Bridge it has been closed
um since uh yesterday morning I believe
because of the high winds brought about
by the oncoming hurricane hurricane Ian
as I said winds predicted to hit 160
miles per hour it's a category for
Hurricane heading Florida's way that
bridge closed and as you can see
conditions there just worsening we'll
keep an eye on the situation in Florida
and bring you developments as and when
we get them